yeah he went sorry welcome to this video
bring down 64 experimenting a little bit
with the other cons getting a third line
played against me that probably should
not be super dangerous going easy
development here Jan do you go see for
here or not I'm probably taking is also
good this is a very good porn structure
for black just ate first here keeping
this tension going here make it more
difficult for him to all the noise tell
Bishop g6 or not room it's probably
helpful I mean okay so he just retreats
okay let's see how to put pressure here
Bishop e3 is even possible try to get to
the pawn now just very it directly
attacking this why not I now move the
nightstand there's no way for him to
defend the corner away like a night to
yourself my bishop has no square as well
jump but I still don't see how are your
hands upon we can go see forward that I
should be 49 okay I can take the rook or
take the pawn this is actually looks
even better the repairs no squares
anyway okay I'm c3 I can take the fuel
now let's take the free book
quite very nice ok yeah let's stick
worked out quite well yeah 93 is not a
move that really puts yeah holds a big
terrorist for black to get an easy
development and the structure is fine
surprise that stock fish wants to play
this and then e six why would you want
to do that I mean I agree that black is
fine but why not play the same thing
with the bishop outside of the chain you
can argue about the capture if you want
to do this immediately with the
structure always will be okay for blood
dumb okay I don't understand why I see
form supposed to be a slight advantage
for white I mean who is this better for
voice okay now it gives equal i get a
queen to defile I mean this must be okay
yeah him jump difficult I mean he's not
really covering this anymore and ce4
didn't work out at all and it's even
stronger to take the pawn I mean you
also give this allows this now okay here
it's a full book not much too not much
to analyze ok guys thanks for watching